- We've been waiting for you.
All this time.
Little did you know,
it would be me.
(suspense music)
Hey, I'm Nick Jonas.
I'm here at Buzzfeed.
And today, we're having a staring contest.
We got some ground rules.
First person to blink loses.
Talking or trashing talking is allowed.
But most importantly,
no one knows they're having
a staring contest with me.
Let's do this.
- Hello?
It smells like somebody famous.
- [Man] Keep your eyes closed.
- Okay.
- [Man] Take your blindfold off.
- Oh, me.
- [Man] Alright, here we go, ready?
- No.
- [Man] Three, two, one, go.
(nervous laughing)
- Hello.
How are you?
- Um, oh (bleep)!
No!
I wanted this moment to last forever!
You can't kick me out, okay.
Oh my gosh, I don't know if you know this
but I was like the biggest
Jonas Brothers groupie.
- Was?
- No, currently!
Oh my gosh.
Can I hug you?
Okay, thank you so much.
- [Man] The only way you
lose is if you blink.
- Got it, okay.
- [Man] Take your blindfold
off but keep your eyes closed.
- Now?
- [Man] Yep!
Three, two, one, go.
- Oh my God!
Okay, can't blink.
- Welcome.
Ah, I blinked.
(yelling in excitement)
(laughing)
It's too long, the anticipation.
- Hi!
- How are you?
Good to see you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Sorry, I blinked so fast.
- [Man] There we go.
Don't open your eyes, blindfold off, go.
(suspense music)
- Oh my God.
- Yes.
We'll give a hug.
- Yes, oh my God.
(laughing)
- Okay, I got it.
- [Man] From the second your eyes open,
you're trying to win a staring contest.
Three, two, one, go.
(laughing)
- They told me to look at your nose
but I made a big mistake.
- You're eyes are really wide.
- I know, I'm drying them out.
I need Visine.
- Do you do a mustache sometimes?
Or is it always the beard?
- Sometimes you just gotta mix it up.
It's usually the beard.
- Um, that's it.
(laughing)
Well done.
- [Man] Alrighty.
- Oh, so much light.
- [Man] Go.
- Hello.
- What's up?
- I like your nails.
- I like your jacket.
- Ahh!
(laughing)
- Yes!
- Well done.
Oh, thanks.
(laughing)
- [Man] Bring it back.
Good.
Three, two, one, go.
- We've been waiting for you.
All this time.
Little did you know,
it would be me.
(laughing)
- [Man] Oh no.
- I'm crying.
Well done.
- Thank you.
- Well done.
- I pushed myself to the limit.
- [Man] Alright, so Sarah.
- Yes.
- [Man] Keep your eyes closed
but you can take your blindfold off.
Go.
- That's what I was thinking.
How are you today?
- I'm good, how, oh I blinked.
(laughing)
- It's so hard not to blink.
I felt your pain the whole time.
- I practiced all day.
- [Man] Shake hands with your competitor.
- Hey, well done.
- A worthy opponent.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- That was a lot of fun.
Obviously, some very
memorable moments for me.
And for maybe them.
See ya next time.
(upbeat elevator music)